ladies and gentlemen zack snyder's
justice league part
four we do our absolute best to get
these public
on youtube and if you're watching this
this means
we have succeeded as per usual i gotta
mention the full length watch along for
zack sanders justice league where you
can sync up with a time code with us is
over at our patreon page a lot of people
have been signing up to our patreon
lately and thank you guys
so much your support means a lot
if you go and hit that like button click
subscribe hit that notification bell
and of course gotta give a big thank you
to eric over at nerd chronic for editing
now these reaction highlights for us
give them a follow today anywho keep a
lookout for part five
enjoy part four
batman is here
and he's got friends do you really think
that
they really just vanish huh oh
that's rude
this score is legit
stairs it's a good song
love this justice league slowly coming
together
is there is there a plan
either of you he looking at you
i heard about you
yes i'm real is this useful
useful damn it we almost got it
remembered wrong
batman's gonna be like oh [ __ ] we're out
of here
oh man we still need more people on the
team i would
die before i tell you
oh amazon
oh
oh
a little quicker
[Laughter]
gotta have a guide oh
oh great shot i need the nightcrawler i
thought you'd never ask
[Music]
oh
nice dude oh cool oh awesome
oh teamwork y'all
dude it's so good like
the feels
[Music]
no
damn wonderful oh yes
[Music]
dude this is so cool
oh that's right
but it's like even with the scenes that
are that were kind of featured in the
other cut
yeah it's just much better
recontextualized with everything else in
between
i'll take it from everything a lot of
old moments here i feel new
yeah do i know you and then like
different music and different editing
pacing style you know yeah
like this whole sequence is so much
better
oh and infinitely ah
what are we under right now
[Music]
ah
my man
i love how so much of this feels like a
real struggle
absolutely yeah
[Music]
omega before almighty dark side came to
the throne
he searched the universe for the
ultimate weapon
the anti-life equation
controlling all life and all will
throughout the multiverse
the world has fought back it is earth
the anti-life equation is carved into
the surface
of this very world
he's turning on his camera and
microphone
my lord
is here
i have turned 100 000 worlds to
dust looking for anticipated
and all of existence shall
be mine
so yes i'll come to earth it shall be so
i'll do all the work for you okay
a lot of these close-ups are gross i
know i got texture
this one's saying she can't fly because
of a software issue but i could fix it
with a little time
you're weird it's all under fish
[Laughter]
you know you're trying to say something
oh i'm saying it
how do we know you're not working for
them it's a long story
you got somewhere else to be
he is freaking intimidating
i had an accident that should have
killed me
but in an act of desperation or madness
they rearrange matter at the will of
their masters regenerate
reinstate reinstate a box has the power
to reinstate anterior particle
relationships
burn down a house the particles still
exist particles of house
become particles of smoke anybody with a
match
can turn a house to smoke
oh my god i actually understand the
mother box
what can't this movie do
i know we're all thinking
you hear the music oh buddy
got it what what a freaking buildup to
superman too like
who is it martha
why did you do that it's ruined
not seen each other since clark's
funeral you haven't been to work since
clark died
the whole world is mourning
grieving over a symbol and i can't stop
them
and look at them and tell them how proud
i am of my son
you'll never love anybody the way that i
love your son
i just miss him
so do i sweetheart
there's anything you need i'm here
come back to the living oh
[Applause]
whoa wow we got ourselves a live-action
martian manhunter
i just really miss your articles at the
tv i had to figure out any way possible
to get you back
but we don't know enough about
kryptonium that makes sense they work
together
man of steel and bbs that makes sense
who's to say that he could defeat them
the mother box did victor's [ __ ]
mother bucks did you
[ __ ] it's like they were afraid
of him
yes they were afraid of him
afraid of the symbol of hope there were
six
not five there's no us without him
[Music]
oh yeah all right guys so that's the end
of part four
part five if it is up there should be a
card here there should be a link in the
description box or a top of pain
comment it all depends on what time you
eventually stumbled upon the end of this
video
either way if it's not up yet just keep
a lookout so subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
catch you guys soon